this show the church of what's happening
now would like to introduce you to pet
net
stop worrying about feeding your pets
the wrong amount of food every day the
pet net smart feeder will feed the
healthiest portions at the right time
every time automatically go to pet nets
get your part get your pet net smart
feeder sorry plus free shipping when you
go to pet net dot com slash joey that's
pet net.com
joeypetnet.com joey show is also brought
to you by onit.com go to onit.com and
use codeword church to save 10 on all of
their optimization products like alpha
brain strong bone new mood swim tech
immune and shroom tech sport
oh [ __ ]
the church of what's happening now
[ __ ] kick that mule league
monday
october 17th
the day the devil was buried at sea
lee cyan
ralphie may
uncle joey
a little michael shankman
oh [ __ ]
break out those [ __ ] bazookas
uncle joey's in your living room tonight
what's happening beautiful people
i missed you [ __ ] ralphie may
here hey everybody how are you yeah you
know hello the same old [ __ ] up crew
it's a monday night october 17th i hope
your weekend was [ __ ] tremendous we
had a great weekend i want to thank
chicago for letting me take my special
in their beautiful [ __ ] city which
i've always loved to death uh
i finally got leo and i turned them on
to a a hot beef [ __ ] combo with no
sausage
with the [ __ ] green peppers and the
onions and
forget about it that's what that's what
[ __ ] me up it's not like the hot beef
with sausage combo right it's the combo
that's it the car oh my god they're
crazy
which one did y'all go to bigger house
house house strong it was close to the
thing there was a world series you know
yeah right you don't want to go up there
we didn't want to go all the way down
listen i don't like [ __ ] around we
were taping i had to do [ __ ] in the
afternoon both days
so we just kept it light lightly and
myself and i got to tell you we didn't
keep working
it was just great it was a great it's
the reason why
i picked that city to do this special
anyway that's it's amazing it's such a
great town it really is they're great
audiences they're like blue-collar but
smart it's a rare thing and they're not
shocked by [ __ ] in chicago
[ __ ] you how nice i lost my phone in the
hotel and they turned it in they turned
it into the front desk yeah a chicago
man where'd you lose at the restaurant i
don't know we were at the restaurant we
had you got up when you saw me you got
up because you did not have it in the
restaurant you got up and you left it
you were sitting there playing with the
phone yeah you put it next to you and
you got up when you saw me and you left
it there somebody
i felt terrible because
somebody i lost i dropped the album when
i got there somebody gave him a great
[ __ ] album
rainbow long live rock and roll right we
went to eat the cuban sandwiches i left
it downstairs that night they called me
in my room
yeah we have you help them downstairs
that's amazing
i'll get it in the morning oh got it
that's great great little city chicago
you know i mean listen man
chicago's one of those places that when
you once you get into the suburbs
it's little last american frontier yeah
right you know
it's really neat you know
i hate that the whole city is being
painted as like the old wild west you
know i mean everybody's dying getting
shot and [ __ ] like that there's only
certain parts of chicago
but nobody gets it it is what it is yeah
right there's parts of chicago that are
[ __ ] bad there's parts of houston you
know oh my god that's so bad yeah the
the different element moved into houston
and those areas where we used to go
probably yeah well [ __ ] up
you know this is going on across the
country yeah anyway you just can't say
chica i mean black people go to
greensboro
chicago is a scary place look what
happened last year in st louis i mean oh
my god yeah tensions are still like on
the verge you know and that's so crazy
because i used to go to st louis as a
kid and and man
i remember in like 84 they had this
whole fourth of july down there okay i
mean
for every white guy there was two black
guys okay we're all listening to cool in
the gang eating [ __ ] hot dogs like
americans all right fireworks everybody
was having a blast i can't believe that
town went to what
[ __ ] is today you know what i mean i
mean it's like i've never seen more
people having more fun and no racial bs
[ __ ] anywhere than at that [ __ ]
fourth of july
it was [ __ ] outstanding cool in the
gang are you st
[ __ ] let me ask you this where were you
growing up that you would go to st louis
uh clarksville arkansas that's funny
because that was the big city for my
wife yeah that's the team you watch when
you grow up oh yeah uh nashville not
well she grew up in [ __ ] paducah
right no in between and no that's
kentucky she grew up in uh what the [ __ ]
my mylon oh my god by mike jackson
that's like jackson yeah a couple hour
yeah
we go to st louis to watch the games
right and then we go to memphis to watch
wrestling and we go to hot springs to go
to the to the horse races my grandfather
would get a place how backup what type
of wrestling was there oh [ __ ] was it
the guys you saw on tv [ __ ] no that we
saw him on local tv i mean that's where
i first met spitting dick murdock uh
[ __ ] the funk brothers okay uh man
jerry lawler i saw jerry lawler and
kaufman [ __ ] wrestle
and then like two weeks later i saw
kaufman get beat by a woman one of these
big [ __ ] from tennessee i mean she's
a big
probably mississippi north mississippi
okay this big [ __ ] whipped his ass okay
i saw that like a wwe wrestler
it's it's third tier but it's legendary
you know i mean it was mid-south and
something else i forget the name of the
other one but i mean
dude i was i went to so much wrestling i
saw ric flair win the heavy metal belt
from uh uh harley race and
it was a second world championship and
then i saw dusty rhodes beat him and
then he beat dusty rhodes again for his
third uh championship
it was tremendous blood was everywhere
it was fantastic
that wrestling was so [ __ ] good dude
i remember as a kid spitting on [ __ ]
uh abdul the butcher i spit on him
you dirty [ __ ] okay i spit on
him who else i spit on um
[ __ ] what was her name were you in like
the front row or was it like oh yeah oh
yeah man all the kids were down there we
were [ __ ] up on suicide cokes that's
why you ever have a suicide i don't
think so okay it's where you take a coke
all right you tell them just a little
ice just a little ice and then you hit
every type of coke oh yeah
yeah that's the suicide getting all
[ __ ] hopped up on that suicide
cough syrup
syrup like like the red night wheels not
even the
ghetto and the green one but i used to
work at the movie theater and we had
good ones
because we had like access to the icys
so we would make up drinks we had like
uh the white icy with sprite or
something we had a creamsicle which was
the white icy with orange soda oh so
good man
that [ __ ] sounds so good right now a
[ __ ] icy
that's
that bong is deadly by the way i just
want you to know i was cruising on
nothing and then [ __ ] one ahead of
that this little [ __ ] mule
it killed what we've had the same bong
three times for a reason because we've
gotten so high we take it in the
bathroom to wash it we leave it there
leave it there
listen
since
you know
i got my first bong let's pretend
1985
yeah i got my first bomb and i went for
the mid-level one
yeah right it was a purple one
i like the plastic with the [ __ ]
pistol grip and the on the car i like
that one hold on this was
because there was glass and then there
was the plastic one like the plexiglass
yes okay but then some jerk off
in 1985 or 86 decides to make a bang
that's purple
with like dark purple hinges
and it had like a carb and the bottom
was flat but it was like this you see
that black surface there what's that
called there on the bottom that's
holding the turntable oh uh is it not
not plexiglass plexiglas it was like
plexiglas okay so
i get this [ __ ] bong and i use it
when she gives it to me for christmas i
use it from like christmas to like march
and then right the bung doesn't suit my
needs no more it's maybe
up to here this bong is what is it maybe
a foot guys
or 12 inches high this bump maybe yeah
maybe put your dick out measured against
you no
dude had to be maybe
18 inches okay yeah so i used the bong
till about mar she gave it to me
uh 85 for christmas
and i used the bong maybe till march 86.
well something i was clean and sober i
was smoking dope when i was dating this
girl and i was drinking but compared to
what i was doing two years earlier
i was [ __ ] clean and soap i mean
lee you say i'm talking about lee
what we do now times 10 but to the fact
that you didn't know
what you were getting yourself in and
this was clean and sober for you this
was clean and sober i gotta say because
people like so there's people in my
family who think i need an intervention
no okay
okay so you want a number to a good
rehab i got one okay so
sure yeah right
you got to assume
from
you know
okay let's be honest from here
to
honest engine honest engine nobody can
read when you're [ __ ] right
i'm just trying to figure that on paper
here i don't have the master scoreboard
that's that yeah right we're gonna have
the scoreboard over here so people could
see it from 80 to 80 from 80 to 85
it was always something you know what
i'm saying
i'm not
uh a package i'm not embarrassed to say
it was no because it went through what
did your mama pass my mom passed
november of 79. but
before that i was already a scallion i
don't want nobody to think that
all this [ __ ] no already i was doing
i was already dancing for money at the
bar at six no no but i was already i had
already by that by that time when she
died i i was already doing acid
nice i had sold acid that whole summer
i was making a living off of acid a
living off a micro dot acid i had it
down to a science ralphie i had it down
to such a science i had to cut a friend
of mine in on it
and then the the real money maker was
black beauties i would get those are the
dollars right the ups okay so i would
get a thousand for forty five dollars
but i would sell a hundred for thirty
five dollars
and then you sold one for a dollar
are you ralphie you said you sold forty
of them and you already got your money
back right and you still had
960 of them to do it there was no you
could only a loser could lose money on
that yeah and i would sell those to
wrestlers no white kids are doing that
now to adderall right so you get the you
get the but not get enough of the
numbers i was getting yeah now
not for those numbers
don't get them from those numbers
and these black beauties were [ __ ]
solid i wasn't getting these from like i
was getting these from these two
chemists that were kids down in [ __ ]
in a college in pennsylvania east
stroudsburg and i remember towards the
end i was opening them up
i was opening them up
and just snortingly two capsules oh so
you figure i i still i i think of lee a
lot when i go home at night i think
about drug [ __ ]
and i think about one particular night
when i was selling purple micro dot acid
i probably had but you know when you
sell it lee
you do it
so remember you build your resistance
yeah so i might sell you one and you
might do one and get [ __ ] up but
meanwhile i got four of them in me right
and i'd be walking around i'd be bumping
into people what's up you got masculine
got me sell to it sell me two hits four
dollars a piece you know they cost me a
dollar eighty not even they were they
were ninety dollars for a hundred hits
of mexico so would you walk into a place
[ __ ] up and be like give me what he
has
no i you couldn't walk into bars our
kids we were walking the streets we'd be
walking on side streets so we'd avoid
the cops on kennedy boulevard
and i'll never forget one night about
two in the morning we bumped into this
convention just roaming the streets of
your town with another kid that's north
you'd bump into people from west new
york you bumped into people from [ __ ]
uh uh guttenberg
you know northbound over north bergen no
hope broken was farther away but the
people locally like you that would be on
those streets
but we we bumped into a kid from saint
joe's west new york and i'm talking to
him he's
loading up his pipe and he goes you got
two hits of basketball i'll never forget
this he bought the two hits and he goes
get one of those hits and crush it up
and put it in the pipe let's smoke it
and dog i almost thought my head was
going to blow up i looked up and i go i
go i've been thinking about this for a
year and now you just said it that means
i got a partner let's do it and we
smoked that [ __ ] acid
and i got a headache like one of those
head headaches did it get you out did
you freak out i was freaking out on the
[ __ ] ass already but to make a long
story short i'm sorry i wanted this
tangible you ralphie no i love it when
i'd go out in those days you really
didn't know what was gonna
happen like all you knew that was that
you had 42 ralphie had 64 and i had 80.
and we're gonna go to a bar and have a
few drinks and maybe a package would
show up
and maybe a quail would show up maybe a
uh
well you know and it was like
that's what i want to say about the
[ __ ] quality like i went from living
this [ __ ]
going to the ball on a monday night okay
like tonight what's tonight monday
monday yeah lee
meet me at uh
at sharples is at eight o'clock okay
they give out food nice and let's have
three beers tell me gonna be at work
tomorrow eight o'clock and joey i can't
miss
because the last time i went out here on
thursday i missed [ __ ] work because
you kept me out there between the
[ __ ] morning telling me stories doing
blow we can't do blow tonight my
girlfriend gets mad when i do blow
dog you'll tell me this before we leave
the house like eight times and you'll
agree with them you won't make them do
blow no what i'm saying is i don't want
to do up monday night what the [ __ ]
wants to do
and also we go down and leave eight we
eat we eat like there's good meatballs
yeah the heinekens taste good in the tap
you know what i'm saying and all of a
sudden somebody would walk in
dog
i got these [ __ ] quaaludes oh my god
the guy [ __ ] up on the chemicals he
put he made a hundred of them but he had
the pan that way so all the chemicals
went to the [ __ ] bottom of the quail
so the ones on this side is the one he
sold us so that like three strength and
next thing you know lee's like jesus
[ __ ] christ okay i'll split one with
you because i gotta get some sleep i'm
leaving here in one hour you see my
clock like i remember people saying it
to me like yeah you see that clock in
one hour from now i'm gonna be the [ __ ]
out of here and i would just sit there
and go
this is when i become de niro in casino
with mickey rickles
remember when the the plane was right
the other day when the plane broke and
now they got you that's me at that point
that's uh that's a [ __ ] uh uh god
damn it um what's his name don rex
mickey richardson at that point lee
that's when you come back and you go
that was paula i gotta leave here in one
hour joey okay don't do nothing to me i
ate the half a koilu that's it no i'm
not gonna have another drink what do you
mean i'm gonna have a drink ralphie just
bought [ __ ] rounds you gotta have
another [ __ ] drink and in that
meantime some skinny [ __ ] with a missing
tooth walks in and goes dark
hey man you wanna buy a grandma blow for
75 bucks
give me 25 and i'll give you a 50 next
one i mean and you're sitting there
going it's monday [ __ ] night what
else could happen here and all of a
sudden fire walks in this could fire joe
lucci's cousin
and he won't he hit a light
you know this was a constant and now we
never had anyone come up to ask me that
they don't even ask you they just get a
drink and also they wave and next thing
you go to the bathroom to pee and then
bam they got you in the bathroom dog you
want to buy these dude they're ten
dollars a piece i give them two for
seven i need the money i want to go to
new york and get my dick sucked okay
what are you gonna do i'm gonna pass out
some good pills lee let's get it come on
get the pass on the pills dude give me
that oh you're crazy [ __ ] 20 lead
come on you never pass give me the
[ __ ] 20 let's get the six bills all
right cut this [ __ ] and that's it lee
that's how quick it happens
you went out thinking you were gonna
have an orange juice
and a hamburger and watch the game and
you're going home jacked to the gills at
five
with a grammar blow in your pocket and
six quails you didn't want
you and your dick's mysteriously wet but
because i owe you twenty dollars i gave
you three of the quaaludes to hold
you know what i'm saying yeah because i
don't want the point yeah because i
don't want him either i don't want him
oh man
george would be holding he didn't even
know it he didn't check the inside
pocket
so that was you pawn off your drugs
essentially no but not no i think some
people carry it sometimes listen not the
coke the coke always went home with papa
okay
don't get me wrong the package there was
no putting away there was people that
said oh yeah graham lasts me a year i do
two lines and put it away that's great
that's great once i stop and they stop
it it's like m m's it's like cigarettes
it's like anything else you put in front
of me i think honestly okay for the
people at home okay
coco is is the head preached man over
church what's happening now
i've been i've been a member of the
church
i might have been the first member since
the first member it was us
and uh yeah okay the last time i saw
coco do exactly what he because he's
talking about the 80s like he was a
demon then
10 years ago
christmas uh no thanksgiving pardon me
uh coco did a quarter ounce of mushrooms
he smoked nearly an ounce of my weed
drank beers all day long and then went
down and did the comedy store and copped
okay and that was the last night of evil
oh an acid acid too you have four heads
i asked oh my god what what he had he
ate a quarter ounce of mushrooms i swear
to god purple okay calmly strawberry
was purple all right and then four heads
of acid smoked at least an ounce of my
weed drank all my [ __ ] orange juice
okay i had to call the canyon store
twice to come up and bring more oranges
how about those sandwiches oh dude are
they still there yeah yeah tell them
about the sandwiches you used to buy
okay i get them to set up a [ __ ]
chicken salad
on toast nice stop without checking this
out yeah avocado and tomato jesus lee
damn lee that was [ __ ] straight
juffoo
we went to that place she took me to
that place and there was ants
in your sandwich and you sent it back
and she still gave you a bill for half
the sandwich oh yeah because she said
that there was only this ants on the one
tell them what size tell me how i feel
where the [ __ ]
the place next to the laugh factory oh
my god yes
take me there every other yeah green
blacks
green flats the [ __ ] [ __ ] charged me
for having a sandwich because they
haven't got it listen i soared my own
eyes oh my god
on his arm and i go ralphie why do you
have ants and he looked at the sandwich
what the [ __ ]
he lifted the sandwich it was like three
ants yeah also he put the sandwich down
he called the waitress over he killed
like three ants because that was in that
she goes what side was it
what side was it she [ __ ] picked it
up and came back with the half and then
the bill and build them for the whole
don't it was the most ridiculous [ __ ]
thing they got they must hire the the
dumbest [ __ ] people dude um i
i went there and uh the time before that
and i got us a [ __ ] salami and egg
sandwich okay that's a strong move okay
late at night boom i had a couple of
pops some stone is bone boom that's
great
and they [ __ ] fried up the salami and
the goddamn they left the plastic on the
outside so it burned it's all toxic and
i'm like what the [ __ ] okay just send
this back [ __ ] it i don't want to eat
anything here then i got high with you
and we [ __ ] went back to that
careful
you have to be in los angeles for food
oh my god nobody gives a [ __ ] yes i
tease them no you always used to make
fun of me because i would get pepperoni
the reason i haven't got pepperoni in a
few months is because they would always
leave the plastic on i'd be eating it
and plastic would come off with every
bite oh my god where do you get pizza
no no i would make sandwiches
oh my god really and it would every bite
would have
the ring around it so i would have to
tell them and like the third time it
happened at different routes
let's get back to something
yes i make pepperoni sandwiches no i'm
not gonna go with the pepperoni
as you're reading it the string is still
on it yeah well you have to take that
off guys i don't know there you go no
i don't think la's problem is it's like
an airport when they cut it they cut it
this way right yeah they slice it like
so it's got the wrapper on it yeah yeah
but not the [ __ ] plastic no it was
the plastic there's something no there's
a difference between the like the
wrapper of the casing i'm i'm used to
that always the case
yeah okay no but it was it was like you
can't take casing and like fruit around
it this like i've had pepperoni trust me
i've had pepperoni before there's no
there's not that and i have told them
and when you tell them that you can see
a difference but that's why i can't i
don't go to the like i did something
really weird today what'd you do what
what did you do oh my god i was shocked
i left my cart at ralph's i got pissed
off
because they like they didn't have what
i wanted and like the deli counter was
full like wayful and i was looking down
at my cart cold water no uh magnolia
that's a busy [ __ ] one that calls
magnolia across from the barbecue place
barbecue place
with the dx you know how's open mic
it's right across it's right past
lancashire oh you go that's hellhole
it's right near everything i go to no
that's the worst one don't go to that
one that's why you get shitty cold cuts
they don't have uh
they don't have good cold cuts there
they don't no no where do you go so the
house up by [ __ ] cold water and
any other rounds but that one they don't
have a slicer they give it to you from
the thing no no they have a slicer yeah
but they give you the [ __ ] they give you
yeah most of the time
no they don't have the good cold cuts
you can't go there you know you got to
go to vineland vineland
you said across the street from the
barbecue place no no no
no no no no not that dump that dump is a
dump okay that's a dump that's a that's
where that jack-in-the-box is there's
something in there yeah there's a carl's
jr yeah that's why you go there there's
a subway too that's why you know why
that is that's why
you don't think i know but i know okay
i've been there
no you can't go to that one you got to
go to one by ventura and violin
underground parking very nice
they got the bread that you could cook
yourself at home
that is yeah what the [ __ ] is gonna get
dealing with you go to the worst you
even picked the worst superman no
there's a worse one there's one on
laurel canyon in victory where they
don't have a deli counter that one's
scary no no i went there once listen the
scariest place you go to is what's the
one it used to be john's oh i live near
that too johnson scary all russian
like get a bunch of newspapers like i'm
about to get shanked in the yard when we
lived in hollywood my wife would go in
and i go oh my god if i go with you
right
parking was scary
everything was scary
one of the funniest jokes about that
place is felipe
felipe goes food for less is the only
place you go and there's drug dealers in
the house
come here
like this
this is a [ __ ]
spoons
he just shot his cd in san jose uh dvd
incentive or whatever special
uh you know he's [ __ ] funny man
felipe's a great guy he's doing a great
podcast with
uh what's up
with my brother silent bob we have to
get in here i have to do his podcast
yeah
wow rodrigo torres yeah rodrigo torres
we have to do his podcast i just been so
busy the last two [ __ ] months so
uh you know listen we're still all here
ralphie i know
i just had willie with me you know
rogan's doing his thing [ __ ]
man joe's doing it big man you know dan
cook is working uh [ __ ] yeah yeah
duncan's working hari's working
we're still here you know
i guarantee that nobody penned us
to be here you know no way josh wolf was
in syracuse this week
he's working you know i mean
i like kids
he was in the house oh my god oh my god
he's in the house oh my god you know we
sit there we were the original
sunsetters you know yeah man me you wolf
dougie
yeah mitch hedberg nick apollo man that
whole neighborhood was rocking dude
i just hung out with dougie just coming
he came and stayed with me and andy
andrus and [ __ ] uh junior stopcar all
right they all came to and hung out at
my house it was [ __ ] hilarious
those [ __ ]
oh my god okay if anybody out there is
in entertainment
uh put a camera on those [ __ ]
they're all degenerates they're all
[ __ ] weird and they're extremely
goddamn funny and they brought over this
these uh these singers bird cloud which
are [ __ ] hilarious uh
google washing my big old [ __ ] okay
yeah that's a real song and uh um they
uh they passed one of them and passed
out on my couch and my dog biscuits uh
went up and face [ __ ] her like
like hey something's wrong with your
lipstick let me touch it up
he had his little pinky tab coco
he's awesome you know
this is what i i think you were there
when i was talking about it yeah this is
what baffles me okay
it baffles me
uh you know when you go on the road when
you watch tv when you're on the road
yeah when you come back from your two
cents and you're sitting there you
little to go box
you know and you put the [ __ ] espn
out and you're going through channels
and there's the orig that's the usual
you have a movie on tnt
you've got something on usa you know
you've got fx has to strand on or
something
and then basically you have the the
three networks you have the pay networks
hbo showtime whatever then you have a
bunch of espn you have more espn
channels than ever
and more fox sports than ever and you're
going through these things
and if there's and at that time from 12
11 30 to [ __ ] two it's these talk
shows that these sports shows have put
on
and you look at this you watch them and
then you try to
you watch them you look at you listen to
the topic you look at the two people
doing it
then you step beside yourself and you go
i'm not even talking about myself or
ralphie may or jane moore who knows
about sports who's got a little sports
show
why don't they have more we could do
this how can brody stevens
is
there we're talking about brody yeah oh
yeah who's killing it on now all this
internet [ __ ] we're doing in my world is
basically
uh
the developmental deals they would give
you 20 years ago
they don't have to pay for them no more
all they have to do is sit tight and go
this guy movement with ralphie may over
here boom give him some money let's see
if we could take this no
uh he's doing [ __ ] periscope
you know he's the king of the internet
as far as i'm concerned oh yeah stevens
i can prove it brody's so goddamn funny
though it's not even about the funniest
it's the [ __ ] he's doing on there so you
need to tell me you're not at home right
now
and your phone rings and goes raffi mate
you know i would never bother you
tonight sir
this is joey d how you doing anymore
joey what's going on listen i don't mean
to bother you there's this kid [ __ ]
brody statements have you heard
periscope i've been aware of it my
daughter watches it if you're watching a
cooking show on there
you should watch this brodie stevens
what would it cost you
to put them on fx92
yeah a new outbound channel
that's for [ __ ]
millennials and crazy people that's how
you call it okay brodie be great with
brodie stevens coffee with brody from
seven to eight
yeah think about it how bad can it be
listen there's podcasts
i know this for a fact and you know this
too they're doing better numbers than
most tv shows [ __ ] yeah
yeah oh my god and i
i think what uh what you always ask me
what i've learned
i think what i've seen
and what the any everyone on this like
sports radio sports podcast
news podcast
not yet they're they're getting a little
bit um
but
they're not
they the thing they don't have is
personality and entertainment and i
think i think the big people like espn
and fox sports don't really want that
they want it to a degree but not really
because comedians oh my god comedians
have taken over podcasts it's not even
close
it's not even and some of them are bad
there are a lot of bad ones but the good
ones
the good ones are could
that's why that's why jay moore is good
because he's he's a comedian he's
entertaining and and there's people on
those sports talk shows that you're
talking about that are just
awful and they have but they have the
espn voice
which is
annoying to listen to so it's like it's
like almost like the athletes when when
they have those athlete interviews and
like oh we're just on to the next team
whatever they're not really saying
anything what would it cost to put lee
with two
with alonzo bowden
okay deadly what would it cost the es
what would it cost espn to put lee
alonso buddy
give me some
jason tebow tebow you could have ian
edwards for soccer like there's there's
a lot of comedians you'll have it's just
mind-boggling it's like
it's just a waste of time i'm not
talking about joey i'm not talking about
i'm not talking about my friends
i'm talking about i'm watching something
that's unfucking watchable there was one
the on that was derek rose and the white
guy yeah
oh my god the white guy is terrible
derek rose i thought he was hanging out
with uh doc gooden
you know he's [ __ ] up
yeah yeah something happened to him
and i love all that [ __ ] at night i
watched that [ __ ] and cheer for it
there's one show with three black guy
one of them had dreads unwatchable
mm-hmm unwatchable you know what they
don't know for tony hinchcliffe they
don't have nothing for the smash
brothers but the smash brothers on to do
a show with a video show behind them
with a video camera two in the morning
this is the [ __ ] i want to see yeah this
is why these channels are starting to
open up watch somebody's gonna go you
know what what's it cost me to start a
streaming [ __ ] thing i put three
[ __ ] shows on it i could stream them
on youtube
brody stevens 24 7. you wake up with
brody and you go
it's from seven to eight with brody in
the morning
and then like 12 to one the last two
stops of the night for bro the comedy
store main room or the original room and
where he goes to eat who he talks sadly
he's deadly he's deadly because he knows
so many [ __ ] people man i mean i
don't think people really understand
i was i was at fox
and tom brady walked up to brody stevens
and was like hey brody how are you
and and that's [ __ ] tom brady man
okay and and he was like oh my god and
phrasing i'm doing good man you know
feeling good doing good positive
positions like positive never hilarious
that you did
it just kills you i don't see it i see
it and i'm not even
bi i'm not even sitting there like i'm
not even close to brody but he's [ __ ]
funny man i wouldn't be like one of
those guys that would go oh look if this
guy could do away but no no listen i'm
old i'm talking about brody stevens and
what he does on periscope
so fun what he does on periscope it just
you know and this is what kills me
sometimes that you don't want to be that
guy thousand people watching this [ __ ]
in the mornings he lifts weights he goes
to baseball games he plays the drums for
no reason he's in the middle of traffic
just [ __ ] just
baiting the [ __ ] out of the steering
wheel with drones listen i get on there
and smoke dope i'm just a fat [ __ ] in
the morning
talking [ __ ] behind a bush you know what
i'm saying i don't have the boys
i don't have a boat like i can't smoke
in the house if i could smoke in the
house i have the cats in there every day
i'd have pure [ __ ] entertainment
every day but i can't i don't know i
know you believe in jesus you can't do
that babies no i can't i can't [ __ ] with
the cats and get high in front of them
and [ __ ]
that shocked him that cocaine thing
would finny he never came back
he lost that fang and [ __ ]
once you lose a fang you're like [ __ ]
this shit's real jack hey i this is
hilarious
i remember uh i mean i was reading doug
stanhope's new book okay
and i remembering all the crazy [ __ ]
we did around [ __ ] hollywood
i mean
everything from
uh
doug there was this guy blackjack
something
okay that doug would just be annoyed by
like so [ __ ] annoyed
and and i'd be over there and we'd be
playing scrabble or something or just
[ __ ]
you know just being you know i'd bring
over coffee we'd [ __ ] go over jokes
and [ __ ]
and uh
blackjack would just show up because he
knew where doug was and doug had his
door you know the screen door open on
the curson apartment and every time you
come in doug would just nonchalantly
slide a videotape of outdoor anal
[ __ ] gangbang okay this girl had two
dicks okay
all right all these [ __ ] and [ __ ] in
there oh my god you're horrible it's
like a blizzard you could turn it upside
down lee all right and and uh
and well well while mouth was a gape
okay
all right
just gurgling comes it's disgusting all
right a [ __ ] fly
came in all right
and that fly was there on the inside of
her [ __ ] when the next dick came in
and you could see it going in and out
with the fly and the puddle of [ __ ] on
the end of that guy's dick all right and
we just be drinking our coffee and doug
and tell me whatever you do don't look
over there don't look nothing all right
just my i don't care what he has what
did you get here when did you get it
exactly 98. okay so i got here
i get here january
29th
of 1997.
coco
okay i'm here a year before you that's a
year a year but bro okay you got to
understand
all right we were all disciples
we're all disciples all disciples
everybody who's really been on the road
[ __ ] knows doug stanhope is [ __ ]
the best rocking today so when i get
here he's a big shot and he's got a guy
from vegas living with him that's a
part-time bodyguard that's a dunce
he only does it part-time like he's just
a [ __ ] he wasn't even like
bodybuilding he's a big fat guy right
yeah yeah he died got rested so he was a
dumpster
you know he was a [ __ ] dum-dum he was
like
doug's gonna make it big and i'm gonna
be his bodyguard he had a big jacket i
don't like belushi so i get here with
the broad i'm living with this girl in
the trailer we get into an argument
she throws me out i'm living with doug
in the bunk bed no
i'm living on the couch or somewhere i
don't know where the [ __ ] yeah
doug's dating the redhead oh yeah from
uh [ __ ] uh the tv show goddammit what
was that show uh head of the clap head
of the class god damn she was hot with
the girl with tyson's wife yeah
yeah she was [ __ ] hot though you
gotta give it to her that [ __ ]
redhead was a hard piece of ass
all right and uh dougie dougie was in
deep into that okay he was like all in
so he used to hang out at coaching
horses
i was never a big
i could count on my hands how many times
i went to coaching horses
coaching horses
was one of those bars ladies and
gentlemen that was just real and you
felt the pain in there and i had been in
bars like that growing up where there's
bars
and then there's bars where if you go in
that two in the afternoon
there's people and there was no light in
there none and there were some people
who were in there that were vampires but
there were some people who were in there
because they thought
they thought they were cool oh yeah and
that was not the place to be if you
thought you were cool they'd suck you in
and spit you the [ __ ] out there
because i did a ton of blow in that
bathroom yeah every time i went in here
it was because i was joeling out of my
[ __ ] mind dougie dougie was the
[ __ ] best he knew i didn't have a pot
to piss in
and he would always like hey man i can
talk to you all right you're a [ __ ]
comic let's go over the coaching horses
all right
and we just go walk over to the coaching
horses and uh it was a a bud light and a
middle light for douglas and just have a
beer and it was i remember one night we
were at the coaching horses and this guy
beside us was talking all this [ __ ]
about
[ __ ] we've gotta kill all the [ __ ]
god damn [ __ ] mother butt [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right and uh and doug goes [ __ ] yeah
and doug's amping him up okay and
getting him with him like this and then
doug [ __ ] grabs my head and makes out
with me okay at the [ __ ] bar all
right and this guy's oh my god what the
[ __ ]
all right and that goes there
all right another beer and a shot that
was a shot that was a [ __ ] it was a
complete it was we were maniacs
complete different times i remember one
night nobody's like that now
so gacked up
that i walked right back to josh wolf's
night
that's when i had the car but the
battery was dead
so i would just go in the car and put
the seat back and lay in there and
hopefully after 10 minutes i put the
blanket on me and jerk off and then put
the seat back and open the windows and
i'd be sweating to death all i needed
was a suicide note and i'd die in that
[ __ ] thing
oh my god is that why you had so many
tickets because you couldn't move it
there was some times that the car would
start and sometimes towards the end it
was a mystery car i had to remind uh
i was just i got to tell you about this
because it's so [ __ ] funny
because we were on the road with douglas
okay
and uh
i remember we were sleeping in his in
his ozone bill cutlass okay and uh and
we [ __ ] reeked of
booze and he was doing the the porno
[ __ ] closer with the beer all over
him so he just smelled like [ __ ]
stale beer cigarettes all right and it's
in houston in like april and so when
that [ __ ] sun comes up it's 110 okay
that's when we both [ __ ] woke up out
of our [ __ ] stupor sweating like pigs
and dog goes
uh ralphie can i uh
can i just butt [ __ ] your titty or
something like that
all right it's really wet get out of
here you [ __ ] creep but that's how
it was he was just [ __ ] bananas he
was crazy he was bananas really really
was crazy he he banged pokey that's
amazing
okay that's deadly
you know seeing him opened up my mind
like seeing dice
on tape that new year's got me on stage
but at night in uh
june of 96
i start i saw it doug snail now and i've
said this before
excuse me i was a host at the broker and
the first time doug came in he stayed
with me i had just gotten separated
and doug stayed with him that was the
house n.c this is 92.
wow then he came out i didn't even know
him there yeah then he came back six
months later and he had the evening at
the improv
yeah he stayed with me again and we kept
in touch for a while then we disappeared
out of each other's radar
and then i get to see how
and people are talking about this
[ __ ] duck stand up he won san
francisco he's the funniest guy in the
country right now
and i'm like this is a little guy with
hair and he's crazy and they're like and
by the way this guy stayed with me hold
on man you gotta give him his dues cause
the guy who came in second place when
dougie won the san francisco comedy
competition was dane cook
okay
and dame was a [ __ ] on stage you
think he's something now
holy [ __ ] that kid lit it up
and i mean
every time standing goes i've seen
mencia get them like that i've seen
chappelle get them like that sam
kennison get them like that
but [ __ ] i'm telling you man
a kid's deadly dude okay then cook and
dougie still beating
and it was it was murderous it was
something that lee it was
completely different than what was going
on at that time
like at that time comedy for me was mtv
and
it was on every channel but vh1 had
comedy on sundays yeah mtv had two
different comedy shows evening at the
improv was out the three shows would put
comics before jimmy kimmel when you just
had letterman and carson you know all
that stuff so you had all this comedy
and then this the first two times i saw
stanford he was just a mid-local
uh racy type comic i thought he was
funny but no funny guys
that time i saw him in june of 96
it drew me [ __ ] off threw me off that
i couldn't even
i didn't go back on stage for two or
three [ __ ] days like it made me think
about
do i want to keep doing comedy
or do i want to get a day job because i
don't know if i can be that good
that being that good is something
completely [ __ ] different dude i had
that feeling when i saw hicks for the
first time
when i worked with kennison and when i
went to dougie and when i worked with
mitch
i got the same thing like what the [ __ ]
am i even doing yeah like what are you
doing that's when you know you're like
wait a second
he's that good yeah do you think it's
like work or do you think some people
just are born with a certain level
i think there's both i think there's
dougie was seasoned he had a certain
thing in his personality that
gave humanity to an act that i hadn't
seen before pryor was great
carlin was great
uh you know i at that time who were nick
apollo i knew from young comic specials
and judd appleton bill hicks bill bill
hicks i didn't really know let me just
think let me just think before i answer
that real quick oh yeah yeah yeah please
yeah by 96 yeah i loved hicks and
kennison and hixson
hicks was great for me
but when i listened to his stuff
it's a little preachy it was a little
preachy towards the end yeah and that's
when i there was there was one
particular tape when anyway it doesn't
really matter once i saw stanhope it
took me three days to realize what my
next move was
three or two days to decide whether i'm
gonna get a day job or i gotta go for
this and work harder but i gotta be that
guy
i gotta be that loose i gotta be that
free you gotta be that dangerous
you have to be that
you know out there
if not you're going to be like the rest
of the [ __ ] dudes that's why when he
came here
he was getting banned from the improv
the time he went to
to the festival and he
that burned victim and he told the guy
they got hit move or some [ __ ]
you know he [ __ ] the chick in bill
maher's bed and he had to write an
apology it was non-stop they had never
met anything like them at that time
he just walked into the improv and the
improv you know they're not the common
store they're not gangsters
they're writers and they you know oh my
god
yeah they're witty and [ __ ] he walked in
there and changed back in the day there
were rumors that he was walking people
on sunday nights like walking the improv
and [ __ ] already that's what you know he
[ __ ] created and he made it on his
[ __ ] terms he went to war with 20 000
club owners
20 000 of them on his terms he got his
ball shaved on stage what oh my god the
chick never recovered the chick who
shaved his balls she ended up getting
raped at the magician castle
what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
just she lost it just from we're not
laughing about her again right now
if you know this girl
it's a [ __ ] nightmare it's a
nightmare it's a that was like the 30th
one right
i don't know what happened
yeah something was not right there but
yeah everybody who shaved his balls that
night was to kiss it that somebody got
into a car accident oh my god
and he hasn't stopped you always
whenever we go on the road with you
you're like you know it's not always
like this for comedians sometimes i stay
in bad hotels like right they stay in
bad hotels every night and they actually
sell
stolen uh hotel bibles
for merch who does that exactly he wants
a periscope one day and he was like
taking
he signed something and when he runs out
of merchandise
and they love a man his fans love him
he's the real
deal he's the real deal man from his
head and you gotta
you really have to you have to
appreciate that especially when you're
here and you see all this [ __ ]
you see people pull up with the nice car
and the ripped jeans and they got the
agent with them and the whole thing doug
stanhope has a [ __ ] manager that two
weeks ago was an assistant manager at a
burger king
and he just met him
what's his name uh
is he no no i don't know which one is
that you never know what doug the one
time the guy had rolling papers and
beers he just met him i no no this is a
different dude he's he's professional
really yeah yeah
he cracks me up this guy's actually got
doug [ __ ] organized and [ __ ]
handled it's incredible
the guy is great he busts his ass
immediately when he came in he got dug
all settled in and [ __ ] uh
found out the ticket counts exactly
[ __ ] went dead merged checked in four
hours before came back make sure doug
was alright had his suit pressed for him
ready to [ __ ] rock and roll
it was it was a [ __ ]
it was that's how a tour manager should
be that guy's in good hands
he doesn't let him he doesn't drink
uh if you got to go anywhere he doesn't
drink he always makes your foods [ __ ]
awesome everything's safe
it's a [ __ ] that's a it's he's the
cleaner okay he's the [ __ ] wolf okay
of of the dug [ __ ] circus okay is is
this guy's wrangling up i mean he used
to leave [ __ ] in his wake and
pop up like once every three weeks or
some [ __ ] he disrupted
a lot a lot of comedians he did
he disrupted their thinking
yeah man even at the comedy store where
that [ __ ] is born right he disrupted a
lot of uh
lineups and
yeah they put him on she put him on at 8
45. oh are you [ __ ] kidding me
because he looked like a nice guy he
looked like a nice guy that's what made
it so dead
he would destroy an a45 i mean destroy
so deep
that would ruin the show he'd
people how does it ruin the show just
it's just
it's over it's over even the comedians
know it's over and once the comedians
you know the comedians are back there
going how could doug stanhope be going
up at 8 45 and [ __ ] night
yeah it was deadly i lived with him
and it was great i got to be honest with
you i used to get up early he slept late
so i get up and leave he had an extra
car for the comedians
yeah but you got to put gas in it
because you the the gas meter was broken
so you never know where you stand so as
soon as you get in the car you know that
was a total scam right was it yeah total
scam that's how the only way you can get
comedians to put gas in scarce
was the needle busted or not no the
[ __ ] needle worked perfectly okay you
just tell everybody to put it together
no it wasn't broken
i knew what i'm telling you i'm telling
you
i put ten dollars but it's one of those
buicks that you go to santa monica and
back it was the same it was the awesome
business yeah the old mobile supreme
[ __ ] yes no that thing was busted jack
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] i put like 30 in
that [ __ ] one time and it didn't
move jack
that thing stayed on the e like that
that car was it like
[ __ ] when he got rid of i think he's
like 400 and something thousand miles on
that car
that's [ __ ] incredible i got like a i
think i even slept in it one night dude
one night he locked me out i slept in
that [ __ ] that's how tough that
car was i was caught i slept many times
oh my god doing cw kindle gigs
it was
shirley bonner she had some good gifts
how the [ __ ]
that was just terrible
my chilling i would walk in your house
at night you have the [ __ ] bloody
marys oh yeah with [ __ ] nut
and somebody else
i'd have like 32 dollars worth of
cocaine in my pocket yeah we'd drink
vodka smoke [ __ ] weed
yeah i never did blow no
risk factors no no no that was a long
[ __ ] time to go down yeah
i was a long time long [ __ ] dog that
was a good building man that bill every
time i dressed i'm rocking man i don't
even go in it i don't do nothing every
time i drive by it
my heart stops i don't i always want to
take a little compadre and i go you know
what man
i'm not ready for that yet yeah right
they go back in there
if they got a good tamale on a monday
night and [ __ ] before and i'm saying but
i took leads to joe's pizza he likes
that better
oh yeah that's good pizza yeah
i don't think i've been at joe's it's
just really weird when you compare
whatever the game is so much
different than what it was what our life
was in 2000 compared to what it is now
and you were already at the laugh
factory yeah you were already making it
happen i mean you know
uh i was over at the store slumming
spots she was giving me response that
was my only right of hope yeah but i was
there you know that [ __ ] building
ricky cruz gavin you i'm working with
him in december yeah yeah
oh my god there were so many people that
had that celine then yeah
the other one gentry you know you just
found the [ __ ] cubby at night to
sleep yeah thank god that was the way it
was that i had the photon for you but
that's why until i busted did i bust
that futon i busted nah i think i busted
it man i think you know i think he
re-busted it
jesus christ but at least you didn't you
know push a turd down my bathroom okay
drain that was always for gavin i
appreciate that
i still remember being out there i was
telling later i'm out there
i was telling lee that ever since i've
been a kid i still remember a [ __ ]
story a horrible thing i did when i was
a kid
i loved matches
when i was a young kid when i was about
five or five and a half or six
i became a [ __ ] a match kid
i went through all these phases because
i didn't have a dad you know i was a
little confused i would lock myself in
my room
and i would take my mother's 45s you
know the from the bar they always give
you back the little things yeah
the singles the singles there'd be kids
playing out there and i'd wisdom
the things out of me shouldn't catch
them in the head and stuff
so when that got boring i said let me
try this
i tried lighting them on fire
and they wouldn't burn like they
wouldn't burn so i put like glue on it
or something and they would burn a
little bit like through the legs they
weren't
like i'm like i throw some indian [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i was crazy
so when i was about six i lived at 205
west 88th street
and if you even go to west 205 88 right
now park the car
and go to the end of the building
not on the amsterdam side but going
towards broadway it's a parking
structure
when we were kids that wasn't a parking
structure
that was a garage that was closed down
and on the wall there was a sign that
said no parking and that was the
basketball thing you had to hit that
with the ball the score
but if you went deep down into that it
was just nooks and crannies and
paperwork
from time to time a rat would come out
of there and we hit we beat him up with
a stick
it was just a parking it was just a
partner
oh this is oh man it was just a parking
spot
a huge parking spot that was empty
but you could get to behind the other
building sadly i'm sorry
no no no keep going you could get to
behind the other building
and in those days i would get like
[ __ ] all that paper from back there
by myself
i can't believe i'm saying this [ __ ] now
because
i've never even talked about this [ __ ]
i would get all that pain but i would
stuff it in that you know like when you
walk down people stairs
and i would like [ __ ] fires
i had to be six or seven i was a little
[ __ ] pyro
and i kept doing it and people kept
[ __ ] like you know it was joey diaz
even then
people kept saying like what the [ __ ] is
going on who keeps lighting these fires
and they couldn't put together that
whenever i got there
that's when the fire would start
like somebody would go you smell smoke
and then i would go yeah it's buying
back there and then people go by
thinking holy [ __ ] there's a fire
and i kept doing this [ __ ] i would do it
in different spots on 88th street 89th
street that was [ __ ] crazy ralphie
man
what did you like about it do you
remember just just uh
because i just i looked some stuff on
fire too see yeah yeah i just like that
i think a lot of kids go through that i
just went through this phase by just
lighting [ __ ]
on [ __ ] fire and i would buy
cigarettes i would get cigarettes
that was the smart way
and i would just i wouldn't smoke it i
would just light it light it light it
and i would breathe on it or something
and i would try to keep it alive and i
would [ __ ] burn little things in
newspaper and fan it i was just crazy
but one time i burnt one of those stoops
dog
and there was something going on that
[ __ ] stoop went up in the fire
department had to come
and i stayed in for about a week cause
they said they had witnesses and [ __ ]
they saw the kid running away
i took that jacket i hid it under my
[ __ ] bed
um that's what stopped me from lighting
those fires anymore but i lit more fires
as i got older
i used to like the woods on fire in
jersey what
oh yeah we were crazy once that [ __ ] got
on popular i was the king of that [ __ ]
i loved all that [ __ ] just getting a
bunch of sticks lighting fires and
sitting there
i wouldn't light fires like the
california people or not in these woods
like this this is woods in jersey
those woods have been getting burnt for
years they don't want to shut off they
shut off automatically you know i'm
saying those are jersey woods they just
shut off no firemen need to show up and
[ __ ]
it's not a union fire no it's really
crazy that
but it just went away it was just a
phase i was going through but you know i
was telling
you know the other day i was smoking and
then flicked the [ __ ] ashes and the
joints and [ __ ]
always at me at least once and leave it
always looking good one of these days
you're gonna like that three on five
and i told them the story about living
in gavin's
gavin's at work i'm on the phone bopping
up and go [ __ ] yourself
i'm arguing with this guy trying to get
trying to get booked in this city trying
to get booked in that city and you know
sometimes you get somebody on the phone
and you're on a roll you know and you
smoke with a cigarette you smoke on a
joint
and all enhances you you're on the road
you're smoking you're smoking also i'm
smoking the cigarette there's the back
alley of
1440.
okay
okay
i love this one
but this is no this is yes
this is across the hall okay
so the windows open i'm smoking
cigarettes like a [ __ ] i'm
smoking cigarettes i'm chasing joints
with cigarettes you know me though
it's 9 30 in the morning i'm on the
third joint i'm on a pack of cigarettes
and [ __ ] camo lights
and i'm throwing these cigarettes out
the window half lit on fire right
and all of a sudden you hear ah
now i did not know there was anybody out
there
i go what the [ __ ] and i keep hearing
this who the [ __ ] lit me on fire and i'm
sitting there who lights up
and like i did and i look out the window
and there's the guy [ __ ] smoking his
shirt or something
his clothes are smoking the poor [ __ ]
guy i go home
the cops don't come nobody knows nothing
i'm gonna compadre that night get in the
package
it's about 10 o'clock at night i walk
back and there's the same homeless guy
with a blanket on and you can see the
blanket
where the cigarette burnt it just caught
on fire and went is there a butterfly
i was right across the hall and the fire
department did come by
oh my god there's anybody i go oh
another [ __ ] bum probably somebody's
just driving through that [ __ ] alley
flicked it on him [ __ ] him oh my god get
that dirty bum the [ __ ] out of our house
guys i feel bad
a little bit once i saw the blanket i
felt a little bad
one time did you get a new blanket at
least one time i had this
[ __ ] black i'm lucky i had to blanket
myself
i was snorting my blanket i was about to
start my blanket i had a choice hey a
blanket was slow
it was oh my god i had a blanket that i
can't believe you just brought up a
blanket okay let me tell you something
me tell you something in 1983
it was maroon on one side and tan on the
inside the one i had yeah the lion the
brown one yes okay let me tell you
something about that brown [ __ ] lion
that brown lion i got that brown lion at
a kmart
this
may of 1984.
that's it
it took me five years but i did i got my
own apartment
and i got an apartment on 48th street
46th street north bergen 44th street
i got a one bedroom studio
on the first floor when i didn't pay
rent i got sneaking through the front
window it was perfect
i was there for about four months five
months and they evicted me
but right before i moved in there i
wanted to go straight so i bought this
blank in 1995.
i mean it was no no 9.99 it was the
cheapest [ __ ] 9.99
i washed that blanket i got evicted
from that place i was homeless i went to
california i came back i caused wars
that summer i went to miami came back
the whole time that blanket was at the
bottom of my travel bag
i had an army bag
and that [ __ ] thing was at the bottom
some places i went they had a blanket i
didn't use it right i always had a
blanket like a biker you you see a bike
yeah man they always got a blanket i had
that [ __ ] blanket
i had that blanket when i was living in
the [ __ ] rocket ship
i would take it back to the runnings and
put it in a little corner and leave it
in there that night go take the [ __ ]
blanket
when i moved into the hotel
in 84 when i was homeless and i got into
the hotel i went and got that blanket
and when i beat joelle for the 1500 i
had that blanket i took that blanket
with me
that blanket was with me from that the
desolate title of my life and that
rocket ship
to
1990 [ __ ] nine when that [ __ ] car
got towed
that car that blanket was even with me
when i went to prison i left it in that
room and nobody [ __ ] touched that
blanket
that blanket was 9.95 in 1984
and i had that blanket for what 15
[ __ ] years yeah and that blanket was
doing the warmest blankets i ever had it
was a bear
okay and on the inside it was the bear
with brown and yellow and on the outside
it was the bear with
yellow and brown you follow me yeah and
then the outside of it was [ __ ] brown
so for 9.95 at [ __ ] kmart
i bought a blanket that went through
[ __ ] hell with me and back jack a
marriage a divorce
when we were married she wouldn't she
wanted to throw it away i go don't
[ __ ] ever throw that [ __ ] thing
away
that thing was in miami i slept behind a
[ __ ] mcdonald's with that thing what
because in those days i would just take
the [ __ ] of clothes out of the army
bag take the [ __ ] blanket out put the
clothes back in use that as a pillow and
put that blanket on top me gee that was
an all-purpose army bag i had i had a
little bit of water i had a razor blade
for blow
i had a [ __ ] wrench in there if i had
to break a window for a car
oh no no lee that that [ __ ] blanket
was there with me
and that blanket i would just wash it
yeah all that blanket won it was my love
and i lost it when that [ __ ] car got
towed in van nuys
it was in the trunk of that [ __ ]
blanket that
that blanket was on the road with me all
those years on triple runs
whenever i got a hotel room that blanket
came into the hotel room i threw the
blanket off and i used that [ __ ]
blanket
have you looked for it online
the same blanket yeah it wouldn't be the
same lee why would i want the same
blanket it wouldn't be the same that
blanket was with me through [ __ ] wars
that
when i lost that car that was the
hardest thing about that tow
when i got that that car got towed like
i thought it was is that the car that i
got my car towed to get all your [ __ ]
out no it wasn't that time no no no no
no this was a car that mainly gave josh
wolfe yeah yeah i got you i got you no i
never got my [ __ ] out of it i got my car
towed to get all your [ __ ] up cause they
wouldn't let you in the line yeah but
they wouldn't let me in the car i was
[ __ ] crazy all i could get was the
back seat and some of the front yeah no
no it was nothing
head shots boxing gloves oh yeah
blankets the [ __ ] pictures when i was
a kid
i had [ __ ] in that [ __ ] car they took
and uh sometimes
sometimes you know so this day i was
just thinking of that blanket yesterday
going jesus christ how long did i have
that goddamn blanket for i wish that
that blanket [ __ ] i would have taken it
to the next eternity with me that's how
that's what that let me tell you how
deep that blanket went
in 1985 in february 1985 i looked at
that blanket one then i go there's
something wrong with that blanket there
were crabs on that blanket
i had crabs and gave it to the blanket
you understand me who the [ __ ] gives
crabs to that blanket i did where's tony
bennett
oh
you give crabs to your blanket
after 400 episodes this song still
[ __ ] hits me the same way it did yeah
when i was [ __ ] six years old
for one minute i go jesus christ
[ __ ] i didn't do my [ __ ] today
my mom would always clean the bar always
clean the bar and always put this song
on
like when she went into the bar in the
morning she'd open up the bar they got
air in there she jumped out the back
door
she plugged the [ __ ] jukebox in
she put ice in the [ __ ] thing and
then she'd start playing this song
and she bucket cleaned the whole place
hot water so yeah
old school soap everywhere steaming off
the floor
[ __ ] sweep it out you know and this
was after the cleaners came at three in
the morning
and i'm saying that's how [ __ ] deep
but she always played the song this song
was always on
this was the first jam to go so i'd walk
in there and go why does he play this
[ __ ] song all the time why you play
this [ __ ] song
your dad gave me the song shut the [ __ ]
up what are you talking about that's why
we play this song on mondays
out of respect sometimes you gotta have
respect and your [ __ ] life is
something oh well i'm an atheist all
right when you're sucking dick in
purgatory
uncle joey you gotta respect for
something you gotta light a camera you
gotta do something you know what i'm
saying next thing you know you're
sucking dick in hell
with [ __ ] deniro and [ __ ] uh
with de niro and [ __ ] uh angel heart
staring you down you're like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] someone posted that
scene today from casino where the guy
was going to i forget i forget the guy
the actor's name was saying like i want
my money back
and he was like you can't have your
money back and they're like let me just
tell you what i do like that whole scene
it just get killed it was amazing you
like that yeah the guy who
uh
played uh de niro's attorney
representing him in vegas
okay
was played by the actual attorney okay
that went on to be the mayor of las
vegas
and he was
apparently
uh
shady as he i mean you'd have to wonder
he'd sue if it was a gross
you know
i don't know i it was pretty incredible
a little shady a little mob lawyer i
love it
that's real
i don't know maybe i watched the dvds
too
well i'm in town uh
doing a benefit tomorrow don't actually
two of them doing
that uh wounded warriors won at the
comedy store all right and early and
then
and then my show at 10 o'clock
on tuesday is called rocking the rest
and 100 percent uh all the comedians are
donating their time
and we got dan cook we've got margaret
cho we've got uh gerard carmichael uh
uh myself uh adrian
a real an actual native comedian okay
all right and uh all the money goes to
pay for propane in north dakota and
these reservations where they're they're
allowed to freeze basically every year
people see their kids die see their old
people die you know indians they keep
their old people with them okay white
folks ship them away put them in a box
okay feed them them happy pills until
they [ __ ] die you know
that's what happens but indians keep
them close and so every year people die
and this is uh keeping people warm who
really need it and so you know i'm happy
to donate my time and uh i think it's
gonna be a [ __ ] great show
and then where you at this weekend oh
this weekend i'm in oxnard i'm at the
new levity live uh in the mall
apparently i don't know i've never been
there it's a brand spanking
i bet it is man they don't really [ __ ]
around dude those guys they kind of get
their [ __ ] together
you know i mean
they're always phenomenal venues
and then when they when they make like
everyone is like let me top the last one
okay like [ __ ] irvine was [ __ ]
amazing when they redid it okay got
umami burger in there that's a [ __ ]
deadly cheeseburger jack all right and
then
boom this one is the fourth one in
southern california and it's the newest
one
they had to do something bigger and
better than irvine
you know they got to step up so they got
another copper blues in there which is
[ __ ] like a hundred beers on tap and
[ __ ] like three hundred probably
flavor sells more tickets to the column
16 people before the show starts
and then the bartender sits in there
like he's got the hip nobody wants to
talk to him for three hours
after the show they look at him like
what we're going there for and they
[ __ ] leave
i'm telling you the truth
you're looking at me all [ __ ] up i
hate those copper kettles they always
got a cover band
copy yeah copper blue i like a cover
back no no not when i'm on stage and i
gotta hit black belt oh yeah [ __ ] some
[ __ ] dude singing black dog and [ __ ]
yeah and i'm on the other side there's
too many things on the [ __ ] menu it's
too big for uncle joy i like simplicity
anyway i'll be at oxnard 28th of
december i'll be right back in the
phenomenal the [ __ ] wednesday after
christmas you know i don't [ __ ] around i
know it's good for you you get to be in
town yeah no no no you got to stay in
town during the home that's what they
shoot the planes down you know these
people going to start taking planes down
with [ __ ] uh what do you call those
things a [ __ ] 50 cal bear no no no no
it'll take down an airplane
oh yeah drones are going to be knocking
[ __ ] out of this guy landing as the
planes are landing and they're going to
take whatever the airport why are you
giving people anxiety now i'm not giving
nobody are you giving me anxiety who
flies more than me and [ __ ] round for
me not you what are your anxiety
yeah oh you gotta know
i live here in the airport
i don't think they're gonna do that
though i think they're [ __ ] i think
they're gonna honestly i think they're
gonna attack a comedy club
i really do and then like you know
blasphemous [ __ ] like us
you know
joe rogan somebody gonna get shot
one of us is gonna get shot on stage i'm
calling a shot
it's gonna be horrific
i hope it's me because at least i can
take
42 nine millimeter rounds to the torso
without [ __ ] stopping i'll get over
there to [ __ ] johnny blow up and
[ __ ] got him with a budweiser bottle
i'm a hero
you're so funny that's what we need is a
poor comedian getting shot on stage and
[ __ ]
poor people that calmly shot club it's
gonna happen no it's not no it's not god
god forbid exactly i want this to happen
at a band ever no never it's horrible
i watched this [ __ ]
a couple weeks ago in new york city and
central park and i'm like how much
secured like if i go to a place to have
a good time
and i see 10 machine guns
you know i was telling somebody tonight
i was supposed to be in new york
for cso i have a bunch of meetings
tomorrow i had one today
and i couldn't do it
but i was kind of relieved i couldn't do
it i can't lie to anybody last time i
went to new york to do gotham i had a
great time i saw my family i saw my
friends i put
flowers on my mother's grave but i gotta
tell you something uh
maybe it's my age maybe it's what i've
become i'm kind of a [ __ ] to all that
stuff
i haven't grown up yet to be used to
going to a stadium you know what's alex
jones crazy man you know
he said something when i saw him at the
ufc five years ago
he said that in 10 years is going to be
tsa at parks
and malls and all this [ __ ]
you know and i can't see it not
happening especially if people are going
to get shot at a [ __ ]
comedy club are they armed people now at
movie theaters
in a lot of states in tennessee there
are
i'm sure there are when i was working at
them they had guards like hired security
or cops during the weekend working on
the movie theaters when that kid
shot the kid in [ __ ] denver yeah yeah
it was the start of it
it was so horrible you know so what i'm
trying to say i mean there's a bunch of
realities involved here with life and
every time i send a [ __ ] plan
every time i sit on a [ __ ] plane
right when i put my luggage up in the
top and i sit down i put my seatbelt on
i go what what what what would stop
right now some guy just running up with
a grenade
well you know you have to think that way
for two minutes so you're prepared
yeah i would always want to well
joey how can you prepare by covering my
eyeballs anything is better than just
surprise [ __ ]
i i know people like to [ __ ] on the tsa
or maybe maybe i have a weird thing not
me my kids fly i
i got felt them both ways there's a way
back i had to stand at it like a
different an angle need to run little
things up my legs it was terrible but it
happened both times
did you get a boner no
listen man
tsa makes me relax
for seven or eight minutes okay but the
reality is that
it's like this oh it's like in russia
right now they can't do quaaludes so
they can't [ __ ] smoke dope they got
to do some drugs that your skin falls
off
right did you see that [ __ ] on that geo
they show these people their skin falls
off no you have to cook it
gasoline will explode i mean
there's always people who find a
different angle
you know there's people like that dude
trying to put a bomb in this sneaker
tsa can only be so good you know yeah
they only do the job they could do man
so you can't
really these with all these attacks and
whatever
listen man
my guys in nashville dude
are so [ __ ] cool man
i mean like they they're like everybody
says hello we have to go do all the pat
downs and stuff and they just like
ralphie was having a high five everybody
even walked the [ __ ] on i mean these
guys are easy breezy extra sneezy those
guys are the greatest dudes and they
just breeze you right through
i [ __ ] love the guys in nashville you
know listen man i love burbank and stuff
but these are the reasons burbank's a
good one dude these are the [ __ ]
realities people that uh
you know i i dread taking my daughter
somewhere like like somewhere crazy like
a [ __ ] crazy airport or
a disneyland type of event i mean you
know but just listen you have to live
your life yeah you can't live like a
[ __ ] cuban down there living in your
corner you have to live your life man
that's why you live in america
who knows and now
they're buying they're bombing the [ __ ]
out of them over there that's how they
retaliate by blowing up planes and [ __ ]
once you start [ __ ] with them over
there right now they're shooting people
i saw them on world news tonight
not with diane sawyer with my other dog
that i saw his long and buried what's
the other dude that i like he likes
stephan umbellus no he's not honest he
only substitutes me let's do it from
time to time
i'll watch him i'll watch step on
opposition he's on he don't buy i like
that guy yeah me too he's not george
stephanopoulos yeah i watched him he was
like some white house
yeah yeah he was good let me give some
[ __ ] quick shout out to my man it was
great seeing the la lingas family in
chicago amazing i love you [ __ ]
the old man came out he knows i love him
it was great seeing pete the greek it
was great seeing josh
from tent [ __ ] planet he took
us over to owls and stuff you know i
want to really thank uh
the club i mean
the management the staff they were great
all week
i want to thank my man ramir shaman
fred nasa
coast la crosstal raymond mayer
nikolai zeppa
shawn charles
jason jackson i want to thank your boys
down there in austin crystal and my man
pop bobby and i'm excited to see my boy
in [ __ ] las vegas next week
larry aka
the toking [ __ ] lair
all next week at the sam at the
south point casino with my man larry
he'll be there friday night [ __ ]
lurking
we'll go eat a little something
then i'll go to bed at 10 o'clock like i
always do you know nobody bothers nobody
gets their feelings they're wrapping me
up no no i'm gonna [ __ ] around how are
you feeling bubba i'm feeling good man
so when you leave see what do you do
wednesday then
uh wednesday um i wake up at radio
um
at
seven o'clock up in
fresno
and um and have my coffee and uh just go
inside and do my show
i really don't like the morning because
i got that that uh
that lasix eye surgery and i have to
wear sunglasses in the morning otherwise
it gives me a migraine headache now i
guess i'm under stress
and um
i uh
i get a [ __ ] bad headache and i think
it's because of that surgery and so i'd
have to wear shades and look like a
douche
in front of people and it's like so
annoying i have to explain myself and
then i kind of look like a douche bag
then too it's like
you know
just wish my eyes did the lasix work did
it take yeah man you know i've got great
vision i can i'm a 2010.
when i when i got it done i was 20 20
the next day i was 2015 and the day
after that everything was healed up and
it was a
2010. i need to get that i'm like 40
something i'm terrible i can't see for
[ __ ] oh really yeah
i can't see dick either so you know and
now i don't know what i mean i can see
little things
i know this
is flow
you know
i know this is
paris what the [ __ ] you laughing about
though bro
it's just like i know this is i can't
see twitter nothing like that
like i can't see my twitter feed or your
emails oh really
yeah i can't see none of this [ __ ]
that's craziness but that's the reality
that's what happened you really post fun
[ __ ] man i mean you got a very eclectic
taste in music but they're always jams
like across genres you know it's really
[ __ ] you put out good vibes
i love it so when i get up in the
morning man i get up like everybody
[ __ ] else
you get up uncertain
like what the [ __ ] is that like i went
to bed last night
maybe 10 o'clock because i would have
had it from the weekend like i slept a
little in the afternoon i kept dozing
off on the plane i got two hours before
i got up saturday night that's not
enough
i got up at 3 3 a.m last night i die
3 a.m just got up
i laid there for like seven minutes i
said what am i gonna do i'm not gonna go
back to bed i went and peed
i put the robe on
i went in the office i did a few bong
hits right
[ __ ] yeah what are you gonna do i went
on the computer
so it was crack-a-lac and i pulled out
one of my notebooks
i wrote my agenda for the day i got my
week ready
right what are you gonna do i did a
couple more [ __ ] amazing oh my god i
did a couple more i didn't even make
that army dude i didn't even make coffee
i did a few more bang hits didn't even
eat nothing
nothing
you're better than me i just went back
to bed
i have a question though about five
o'clock sorry go ahead
about five o'clock i went right back in
there like a doctor lisa
it was
freezing i took that t-shirt off my
titties came out
i put that [ __ ] blanket on with that
sleep apnea mask and i climbed under
that blanket
i slept on that [ __ ] alarm went off
at 10 after seven
and i would have slept till nine trust
me
i would have gone deeper than deep
what's your question i'm sorry sir my
question was about saturday night what
up
because you
you we like we talked after and you were
like you were really pumped after
and i like i was just i never knew like
did you like
like what what did it feel like what
like when you finally got to the hotel
room like what did you do
that's a great question
i sat there and just
let everything cool off
i didn't even know what was going on i
had no idea what was going on with me
i knew i just wanted to sit down
you know at one point i took my shirt
off from my shoes
i wasn't getting anxiety it's something
else
it's a different feeling i put the tv on
and tried to get interrupted by the tv i
think i called you
i called a friend of mine but nothing
really mattered
so i got up and i went in the shower
i put the shower on as hot as i could
i just sat and let the [ __ ] water hit
me too
i couldn't take it anymore and i let the
water cool off and i stretched my back i
put shorts on and went right to bed like
that
you just passed out just passed on
whenever i'm confused and [ __ ] i need to
go in the shower
i just go in the shower and let it run
on my head
and let that hot water [ __ ] regen
rejuvenate my brains [ __ ] cells and
[ __ ]
and that's it
because ralphia you've done
a lot of specials
and even your early ones were all of
this is joey's first so like going back
to your first can you think about like
what that like was that was like
well i
mean i've been running those goddamn
jokes
for like five years straight i mean i
had laughs every
four to five seconds
and
uh
the album went platinum because people
thought i got
[ __ ] out of last comic we sold like
1.4 million
and um
i was
it was it was a big deal and uh
it was just out of the laugh factory and
and but the feeling afterwards
like you're like
oh god
there you know there's like oh my god
there's a like you get to exhale
all right and then you really take it in
and then it'll come if it hasn't already
the panic that
you can't do those jokes no more
because people are gonna see all that
[ __ ] coming and you you're not the type
because joey's a real comedian he won't
allow himself and he'll beat himself up
to dig deeper and go realer okay and
that's what this is gonna do it's gonna
it's gonna act as a catalyst to spur his
writing and in a [ __ ] year he'll have
an hour and a half and
uh that's how it is but
for like the next month he's gonna be a
little bit of a panic
all right and no i'm in no panic at all
good good let it break at all i'm in the
state of
where are you at
where am i i'm in the state of because i
know the whole [ __ ] thing
no i'm in the state of uh
it all came down to this i enjoyed doing
it i definitely want to do another one i
know exactly what i want to do it
i know exactly where i want to do it i
know how much time i want to take
i know i'm going to do it now so you're
ready with a whole another special i'm
ready with no other special i know
not even close
i have minus 10 minutes for this special
you know
you know what i'm saying like you're at
that point i'm not worried about that
i have i'm gonna take this week off
and then start next tuesday night man
and then boo boo boo boop go to vegas
take a week off up up up up go to boston
go but you know and i'm still going to
have i'll get some more material put it
together for these tours until you start
to play i'm like janet jackson now when
janet jackson starts a tour she lip
syncs she's got no cardio it's tough to
move and sing at the same time
so you started 90 [ __ ] lip syncing by
the end of the tour you're down to 10
percent i'm singing because
you built your [ __ ] cardio you don't
need somebody singing behind you the
same [ __ ] they've heard you understand
me yeah that's how i'm going to try it
that's all i'm going to try for right
now
i'm in no rush you know plus most of the
tours before the specs there's a lot of
things that people always say you think
you're in a rush
no
we're in no rush
not at our level i mean
it's like it's like i i did my special
when i was
11 years in
okay and i i hit my first special
and
no 12 12 years in
yeah 12.
and so when i hit
i knew what i was doing
you know i've been headlining all over
the south for years for years no no when
you hit you were already ahead i had an
hour and a half ready
yeah you had you had that night and the
next night if you come tonight and
tomorrow you're gonna see two different
[ __ ] hours yeah no experience takes
the handle over here i'm not worried
about the material
i'm not worried about any of this [ __ ]
this experience taught me that
you might not have anything in may
right but if you keep getting on stage
and you keep taping your sets and you
keep pushing yourself that that what are
you going to do tonight i'm going to do
three sets really
yeah you're still out there banging
after that because you forgot there's a
dodgy game
so that show that was supposed to start
at [ __ ] nine is now gonna start at
[ __ ] 10 30. so you're out there till
two in the morning working your material
for three [ __ ] people but every spot
works
it's really amazing how
a friend of mine once told me that
everything works in layers and i didn't
know what the [ __ ] he meant
it meant that everything you do builds
and it builds momentum in one day it all
builds into one momentum
all those little things that you thought
was [ __ ] all build and they really do
i'm seeing it with 20 people now
i've seen it with 20 [ __ ] people
from ralphie may to [ __ ] ari to ali
wong i've seen
momentum build over [ __ ] night like
nothing happened so stand-up is real i
can't imagine being kevin hart
i can't imagine being amy schuman i
can't imagine being louis ck
because those guys asians get greedy
they put him out there and these guys
can't write fast enough
these guys can't ride fast enough
you know when you get to that level
you're doing 80 other things
it's not you in a [ __ ] room anymore
yeah you're not doing bong
it's all different it's all different
now so people can't adjust to that
either i was telling lee that one of the
most important things is grounded no
matter what ralphie had around them at
all times the six agents the whole thing
i was always hawking them on the phone
tormenting them making them laugh
keeping them grounded so he wouldn't buy
into the [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't buy
it they're gonna hit you with [ __ ]
that's it that's it
there's a ton of [ __ ] that comes
with it if you keep your friends around
they keep you grounded you know what
ralphie that joke ain't funny
when that agent tells you that that joke
is brilliant we love it you're up there
eating dog [ __ ] like that poor kid on
today's show corey feldman singing that
[ __ ] like god you know can you
imagine this poor race
what are you always one of them loves
boys to come and rip his [ __ ] head
off
what do you do
when you're that kid's agent and he
comes into your office and he sings that
song for you
you can't sit him down and tell him the
truth
somebody's lying to that kid well that's
tremendous well get me on the show right
now let me call in two minutes let me
call when you get out of here no no i'll
wait call right now
i got corey feldman in my office right
now he'd love to come on today's show
and sing a song really
thompson sent us a demo
they sent us a demo of that [ __ ] song
without looking at the kid he shows up
with the two broads dressed up like
[ __ ] vacuola
yeah dressed up like [ __ ] white
dracula what about them what about
auditioning for that role for what role
the the two women i know one of them is
probably his girlfriend but
the other one i don't know those poor
girls didn't know what they were getting
involved in to trust oh my god
those girls want to shoot themselves
right now
those girls have changed their hand
color they
they quit sag and joined after
they [ __ ] switched governments those
two [ __ ] little girls our generation
had those uh
those chicks uh
from the guy yeah
it was a good song good singer
basic same formula mine is a good singer
a good song
okay if they just had a good singer and
a good song it'd been great you know
that was
music at that time was like on tv
the better your video was on mtv the
more tickets you sold it really wasn't
about the music and the music was good
yeah the visual effects to the [ __ ]
videos in 83 and 84 were [ __ ]
brilliant from sledgehammer
sledgehammer thriller thriller those
video and that's what sold tickets at
those times
that video uh the lights are you know
what he's talking about lee
yeah no no do you know what he's talking
about
put on uh youtube real quick i'm gonna
give you a lesson in tv and music right
now what's our shirts put on robert
palmer
just put [ __ ] youtube on lean when he
asking questions well goddammit lee is
it time for another mushroom cap no it's
not you don't even get off on those
mushrooms
i'm not i'm only getting off a little
bit it's time for another mushroom
that's doing that i'm not doing
mushrooms brother just me and lee
this is we're in training lately we're
always in training that's what what
trump which proper promise uh
addicted to
you never saw this like no okay oh this
is tremendously let me just get this
[ __ ] and you know what they've done
10 videos 10 different things to copy
this oh yeah but i think this guy was
the first guy i don't know if that's why
i don't want to say for sure this is the
first guy i saw do it that really made
an impact on me
watched it you never saw this lee unless
you showed it to me oh my god seriously
watch this there's no talking about
thank god
watch the screen lady don't watch
nothing though
oh [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ]
holy moly look at this [ __ ] at least i
am wow
bam
nobody's got balls like that
nobody's gotta sound like that
put on robin palmer i want you
this is what you know this dude is
dangerous this guy has always been
danged nobody knows about this guy
nobody remembers this guy because
everybody thought he was a pop dude
this guy was a pop dude
but he went deep with some [ __ ]
right there right there
listen to this
god i wish i was here hearing this for
the first time
so he went into he went into this marvin
gaye thing after marvin gaye died
right and this guy was [ __ ] pulling
it off lee
a white dude
took marvin gaye's music and flipped it
he flipped at this dude
nobody said
dick because it was that good
is this the real music video
yeah
this is early mtv
82
no this is a little later
i figured that other [ __ ] was 84 83
this is actually got a little bit more
popularity yeah he wanted to switch it
around on the [ __ ] and show
people he how deep this [ __ ] was
he's like a bad day
now split this up a little bit ladies
he really breaks it down somewhere here
go right there
there you go
there you go here's where he turns it up
kill that way
thank you
that is some bad ass [ __ ] right there
because i hate covers i hate all that
[ __ ] and when i first heard this
i looked at him for a little while i go
you better not be doing what i think
you're doing
but he sounded so good and i watched an
interview i was like you know what man
this guy is a dangerous [ __ ] is
this thing i like all this type of [ __ ]
people like when a guy takes
a thing and puts a spin on it what's up
lisa are you ready for another mushroom
cap you're gonna sit there it's monday
night it's the 17th of october you got
dick going on the 18th
anymore i got nothing going on the 18th
oh my goodness i might as well let's do
it
did we finish all the animals oh yeah we
had what one and a half
three hundred gummy whatever 300 maybe
fifty that's nothing we split very much
cooking 350.
we're gonna get a nice sleep though
we'll sleep when you wake up you think
you got [ __ ] two massages and [ __ ]
it was a lot of fun when i went back to
the room
i was very uh i felt i i had done
something that's what i felt like i had
learned a different concept of comedy
that i had never learned before i had
never known and i never really thought
about it because i never thought i would
shoot you know what i'm saying like i
never went there with my head yeah i
kept it simple but i gotta be honest
with you i feel the same way every
saturday night
after i do five [ __ ] shows really
yeah i'm done i'm [ __ ] done man
especially if i [ __ ] around the daytime
and work out and stuff and think i'm
tarzan on saturday and do the elliptical
for 30 40 minutes and i go on that
[ __ ] stage and do two shows i'm not
saying i'm everything hurts my whole
body is electric
sometimes i only got four hours so i
know the shower
will [ __ ] wake me up and i don't want
to do that but this week that's the more
that shower was one of the best showers
that
two weeks in a row i had a great shower
last week in columbus ohio i went in the
shower for so long the fungi nail peeled
the level you know what i'm saying
a [ __ ] fungi nail powder
like a big ass dip size freedom it was
the only week i didn't bring my tools
with me
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] soft like that
you have tools oh i have this whole kid
i got the comb i got the [ __ ] little
eyebrow cutter i got a scissor for your
nose
but then there you go on the other side
you got like a [ __ ] you got a needle
to mend a [ __ ] uh like a sub button
i got one of those in there
that needle works for everything
what does everything mean everything
hash
ingrown hair
that could you know that could work on
stitches anything that anything goes
with that and then i got a toenail
cutter that's [ __ ] huge i can cut a
[ __ ] i can cut a gorilla's [ __ ]
toenail with it
right i got that and then next to it
there's like a chisel so you pick up the
nail and you go in there deep and you
chisel that fungi out it looks like
[ __ ] it looks like
it looks like fungus and blue cheese put
together
when it gets wet you cut the nail in
holes it's tremendously
shout out to buffalo what's the matter
you look a little dizzy
vomit
ingesting all this information oh my god
you wanna eat another mushroom capital
not really to be honest but i will all
right let's do one what the [ __ ] it's
monday night it's the 17th of october
ain't nothing going on okay
i got i was supposed to have something
eleventh tomorrow it's not gonna happen
so i'm just gonna [ __ ] do my thing
yeah
i don't bother nobody you know what i'm
saying right you look good lee we had a
nice time this weekend i learned a lot
you learned a lot
congratulations to you both yeah
thank you thank you to joey like i said
man not you too lee like i said man uh
it's a pleasure to see your growth you
know
i was always happy about all your
success
you know you see all these guys that you
all came up with
and everybody rates success differently
you know what i'm saying
i listen man
i don't want to sit in the [ __ ]
outside and let peop you know us man
we've been we're stoned 82 hours of the
day
the last thing we want is human contact
you know what i'm saying i don't want
[ __ ] tmz ever to question me about
something
i don't ever want to be one of those
guys man i just want to be a dirty man i
hear that [ __ ] so much i just want a
dirty comedian that's it i don't want
nobody to even know i exist
i would never want to be in amy
schumer's shoes god forbid i would never
want to be in louisiana everybody gets
so critical of you oh you can't be a
comedian anymore when you get to that
part of common yeah because it's too
rough
it's too rough no it's too rough because
look at people get offended about they
oh everything so it's too rough to even
go there so you don't want to be in that
particular spotlight if you're going to
be in that spotlight you have to have
three writers that write
you know material that's uh yeah that's
great policy friendly i rather shoot
myself in the [ __ ] head next topic
what else [ __ ] talk to me you
smoking weed what's going on you're
doing jumping jacks over that lisa
you ready for another mushroom we got i
found some acid hidden under one of the
albums and [ __ ] a half a piece can you
imagine
we could break our own record tonight
if anything if you feel anything weird
okay
go to the safety center
about the sofa leave it just write it
out okay
lee knows all about this you want to
take a shower and take a big old [ __ ]
i'm telling you that's what i got leno's
all about the sofa lee has been on that
sofa a couple of times he's a soldier
leave my little lea alone i love him he
goes when does yom kapoor finish i think
it's over it's over that's it where's
the next big jewish holiday
hanukkah maybe hanukkah i don't know
maybe there's something in between that
that people need
and let people know well we always gotta
get one more well we got halloween right
you know how what are you gonna be for
halloween though i'm gonna be in
nashville
nashville yeah you're not doing comedy
on that and that's right no
what are you gonna do for halloween
[ __ ]
i'm gonna hand out uh real size candy
bars
see everybody comes to the house
what do you mean real size candy box
well you know those fun-sized candy bars
yeah [ __ ] there's nothing fun about
them i know that you just get started
and they're done
[ __ ] that i give whole candy bars
i go to sam's and get [ __ ] cases out
of them you know man you might shut out
there
when you open up a real candy bar you
know where you stand right
like i appreciate children you know
don't don't toilet paper in my house
you know what i mean i'm your man okay
we're down okay you know you pay the
neighborhood it saves the way pick
offense from getting [ __ ] up okay you
know i mean just pay it forward a little
bit okay then mom will come up i'll hand
them three which one you like reese
okay well it's [ __ ] is bomb too oh you
want some milky way this is all caramel
okay that's all i got i'm sorry all
right but i mean i go through
probably 300 dollars worth of candy
but it does i mean kids just light up
and i get toys and stuff yeah this week
this now i'm gonna give um neighborhood
i buy the pint-sized ones but you're
right when you have the little [ __ ]
things what happens is like me this week
with the butterfingers i just wanted a
butterfinger next thing i was eating 22
of them which meant i ate three of those
life-sized ones if i would have just
stayed the life size when i know i stand
all right that's it i'm good to go you
know me at the control of a [ __ ]
savage
i could say [ __ ] it that's it i had a
few of those butterfingers
too i saw those you were talking you
were tearing [ __ ] up this weekend
i was not
sure which i'm proud of you i'm proud
listen you know me dawg i ain't no slim
jim i don't give a [ __ ] i want you to be
healthy but don't sit there look me in
the [ __ ] eyeball and go i don't know
who ate these two pizzas i didn't even
know that
two pizzas disappeared
there was three of us two pizzas i was
on stage for two hours i come back he
said
he's sitting there with a big grin on
his face happy as [ __ ] no there were
veggie pizzas
there was no veggie pizza they were all
veggies
i'll strangle you i was eating them they
were not veggies i wasn't i was there
with cheese and prosciutto
when i got back there i had no pizza it
was just veggie ask willie get willy on
the phone wait a second when i got back
there was two slices of pizza because i
didn't want to
leave stop stop you're soaking my
intelligence
i wasn't in the state folks he's saying
the back room there's no backbone there
was no nothing there was one [ __ ]
room
three slices in the in the main room i
did i ate three slices that was later
yes yeah no no no somebody ate the ones
in the green room not me when i left
there was a pizza and a [ __ ] half i
was sitting in the state at the table i
just saw a link no no no no i wasn't
there was a whole pizza that was
willie's and there was a pizza i took
two little stuff
you know he knows a little [ __ ]
those little [ __ ] pan pizzas hey yeah
there was two little strings that come
back
two little slices when i left i took
both of them he ate one i watched him
and he ate a piece of chicken nugget and
he was eating them he's saying what
vegetable the pajama lashes vegetables
there were no veggies
i come back and there's no pizza and you
sit there with a grill
high as [ __ ]
high as [ __ ] he was
and i go what's going on
i know he goes back to the hotel room
the next day he's talking about chicken
cutlet parmesan from before his wife
just got sick eating [ __ ] on the road
and also he's out there ordering to go
for it if there's no because at the
hotel at two in the [ __ ] corner
you're talking about two different
nights now are we talking about saturday
or friday where'd you go friday night
friday no no friday night was the
chicken farm
and what it come with me french fries
there's no pasta
pasta yeah you ate pasta three in the
morning just a little bit of that i hate
like emotion
i promise he always eats a little bit
yeah and what was it
the reason why i didn't i didn't was
because i didn't include cheese so i
couldn't eat most of the pasta
um and saturday saturday was because i
had like two slices and yeah it's
[ __ ] edible listen to me
ralphie they bought new wave bought ten
pies yeah a ton of pizza they're so cool
all those things
are always good yeah now
lee was sitting right there
i had three slices i had three slices
plus the 15 slices
no but that's like a pounded pizza i was
talking to the photographer ask him
that's the whole time you look in your
fingers
ladies and gentlemen of the court i'm
watching like a horse
he's sitting there listening
lee was like me in the 80s with cocaine
if cocaine landed right here i'd be
sitting next to it making believe it
wasn't there like how do you know oh is
that cocaine that's not mine
i'm saying like lee was sitting
at one time we had three [ __ ] boxes
of pizza
sitting there like like sinatra
mingling with the boxes of pizza
you yell at me all the time for eating
garbage pizza i'm finally surrounded by
good pizza and you ate that and then i
want to take them home i don't want to
take them home and say no no i didn't
say no you did too and say no no i did
not i go leave you embarrassing me just
eat the pizza here well
you always want to have a slice of
sports center or something then he goes
back to the hotel room he also and he
orders like stamina pizza no it was good
i went to the front desk
oh so it was a good pizza because it was
the fun [ __ ] well at least at least
maybe they would i would recommend a
decent what was the brand i don't
remember
yeah i know it was like two in the
morning four years i got like the
smallest one it was so it was so
depressing four years of college it was
like eight inches it was like eight
inches or what [ __ ] dude that was
just pepperoni you were fighting on the
plane the next day
so are
who almost jumped out of the plane
because you were farting and then i had
to fall back to retaliation
and
he's not admitting to it at least i
admit to it i love farting on planes you
didn't fart on the way there that was
all made all right you were half a fat
no you sat there like a half a [ __ ]
i blew this guy out the first time i
my back was bothering me
so i bent over this way to farm yeah but
it flew out of my back
and i heard it i felt the back of the
jeep
flapping like a [ __ ] like a kite
and i sit back and within two minutes i
see lee look at me make him believe like
he's doing sign language and he's
inhaling that fart because the filter of
the plane is on the least feet
that's why you never take a window seat
because everything that comes goes right
there to the window if i sneeze it goes
to the window if i blow my nose it goes
to the window if i fart
so lee gets the first dose of the fart
this guy gets a second dose like that
hurricane last week was supposed to come
back oh yeah this fight comes back
this part goes deep and it breaks it's
like a wave right
it's like a wave it breaks like this
half of it goes lee's direction the
other half hits the middle seat
and ricochets right into this guy's
mouth you understand me i know how to
fart in that first aisle i've been doing
it for 10 [ __ ] years
i started on rogan that's the first
guy's car
because that's first class that's jerky
you got to catch him when he's sleeping
and their mouth has to be around here
rogan would sleep by the window with his
mouth facing up
that's tough to catch him with a [ __ ]
fart i'm telling you guys
i don't [ __ ] around i'll tell you how it
is
on the way back i i got upgraded to
first class it's sunday flight on the
way home i always got upgraded
i walked back to check out my lily
leland
killing it
i give him an edible before we get on
the plane we started the flight at 7 30
a.m
with 200 milligrams of death a joint at
the hotel oh yeah we don't [ __ ] around
and we had just gone to bed right yeah
three hours before three hours before
killing it the whole week
current michael was there the whole
[ __ ] you know
everybody's [ __ ] smoking dope outside
and
we get on that plane i get upgraded he
goes back to 14 d like
no he wasn't really in the dungeon
he was in the middle of the dungeon
they charge you for those seats now from
fourteen
fifty bucks if not they put you in the
[ __ ] dungeon dog and let me tell you
something you fly anything now from 16
back
you're gonna get sick you're gonna get
sucked you're gonna get abu
if you're in that 28th row by the
bathroom
he'll have fury on you because people
are back there farting that fart's got
no way to go you got to sleep with a
blanket on your head and the straw
coming out of the [ __ ]
you think i'm kidding you listen you you
got anything from 24 to 28
when you go home you gotta take a shower
you can't even [ __ ] go out and meet
your friends and hang out because you
got this [ __ ] layer
of airplane trust me dog we used to sit
in the back of the plane those are the
cheapest seats those are the ones that
are yeah when you go on there late and
they give them to you cheap seats for
189. i just got my tickets for boston
i'm sitting in like 21 and 24. there's
nothing
there's nothing unless i wanna pay like
a hundred bucks a ticket which isn't
gonna happen so
i'm sitting in the back are you on
virgin no jetblue oh look at you you're
sitting in the back on both flights yeah
what is it but don't you have to go out
of long beach no no that's awesome why
would you go to long beach we're up here
i thought that was down in long beach
only they have it there but no no okay
but anyways um on the checking
when you were checking on me
oh yeah i went back there i'm bored in
first class i walked back to check out
my little nephew lee
he's got the he's sitting back there
with a smile on his face like he just
hit the ladder
he's got his shoes off no i don't know
no i do not
first of all i i taught him how to fly
yeah right you understand me we get
through security he's a [ __ ] mook
he gets stuck as usual because you don't
know just to keep going
right because i got the pre-check this
[ __ ] guy's walking around like he hit
the lottery like at least speed up plus
he has 19 bags i'm right out and i have
one bag he's gonna say like he's gonna
have a surgeon
he's got the computer and the games in
there and god knows what all this [ __ ]
he's got
god knows what this city's got that
don't belong i got two things on my
thing
i got two things in my travel bag a
sleep happening machine
and a computer yeah you're the one that
draws the attention no i don't i don't
take none of them out stupid well
i haven't taken that computer out in 20
years they always say if you have a
computer or laptop take it out i haven't
taken it out at all that's how i run i
don't take nothing
leave it in there shut your pie hole
take your sneakers off take your [ __ ]
belt off
take the tickets out of your pocket take
your cell phone and put it in your right
shoe and take your wallet and put in
your [ __ ] left shoe so they can't rob
your [ __ ] suck instead you get shaken
down
your shit's all the way over there out
in the open you understand me
so guys like you with the suge knight
shirt on look at him ralph you have the
sugar nice shirt on today
smooth
you have to [ __ ] do this [ __ ] tony
rob john cause those tsa guys will rob
you
really oh my god your wallet go missing
and you have to run the tape don't get
rid of the tape it's a conspiracy it's
like the trump keeps saying the media
[ __ ] that oh my god
so
we get to the airport i leave him there
i was gonna wait for him like what would
he rather have me away from a nice
breakfast away from him
he [ __ ] goes through security takes
them an hour they search him they bring
the [ __ ] bug the dog
they brought the donkey everybody to
sniff them
i go to that [ __ ] macaroni grill i
get them a nice sausage platter with
eggs and potatoes and sausages he gets
out of security gets over that boom he's
got it waiting for him with a [ __ ]
diet coke yeah perfect like a [ __ ]
doctor that we are right i mean i gave
him six minutes to eat because we you
know yeah
we gotta get on the [ __ ] plane first
this [ __ ] homework i got a
superstition i gotta get on there first
and get off that [ __ ] first okay
so i tried to sneak him in but i
couldn't do it but he went to the back
it was cool it was a good little flight
it was a good little [ __ ] trip man i
like uh
i simplified traveling on the way out i
had a yell at a guy with a volvo oh
classic because he tried to play the
white [ __ ] supreme game on me that he
was better than take up two aisles
so i played his [ __ ] card and the guy
fell apart at the seams
at the parking window even the black
ladies were laughing at him dog it was
[ __ ] embarrassing
he wouldn't pull up he wouldn't open his
window it was the worst thing ever
lee scared the [ __ ] out of him he told
him go [ __ ] your mother
it was hysterical
the flying jig out of nowhere
let me do this guys real quick yes go
back let me talk about one of my
sponsors on who i love daily i mean they
um i'm our bread and butter they've been
with us since day one i love the death
men
and i love them because the products are
[ __ ] solid at least the products that
i use are salad
it's the [ __ ] shroom tech sport
it's the hemp forest protein the
chocolate and it's the alpha brain
that's my studies right there listen my
kidneys can only take so much i take
blood pressure medications cbd oil reef
and cocaine for 30 years they ain't got
much left so
i got to be careful what i'm [ __ ]
putting in my [ __ ] things but i love
on it
i believe in them yesterday when i got
home right before i take a flight i take
that [ __ ] alpha brain that's why i
don't fall asleep on a plane when i get
off
i sleep two three hours i got no jet lag
it's alpha brain but do me a favor
go to hunter.com right now
and look at the great selection of
supplements they have if there's
anything you like
go to the cart put it in there press in
church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 percent off your
first order deliver it to your door okay
if you like what you get go on the stay
on it program they deliver it to your
door on the first of every month you
gotta do dick all right go to honor.com
and press in church and get 10 off your
first order number two i want to
introduce you to a new product
that we're putting on the podcast that i
[ __ ] love uh when i left
they said they were gonna send it to me
and when i got back they sent it to me
and i asked my wife what do you think
and uh
she loved it i mean so far so good
you know i mean i got cats man
and you got to feed the [ __ ] cats and
cats like to eat on their own goddamn
schedule
if you have one cat that's great you get
to loan their schedule you have a couple
cats
that ruins it okay that that ruins it
because you don't know what you're
eating so sometimes you might feed you
think frisky is eating and frisky's
really not eating it's [ __ ] lulu
that's eating everything so every time
you put a thing out frisk you don't eat
so lulu eat all six [ __ ] times and
meanwhile for two days
frisky looks like that [ __ ]
cat with flies on him in africa like
he's [ __ ] hungry and [ __ ]
so do you ever wonder if you're over
feeding your pet
sure studies show feeding your pet the
right amount every day will help them
live longer but how do you know you're
feeding your pet the right amount of
food every day you know
i mean
this is how this is one way introducing
the pet
the pet net smart feeder the new
smartphone controlled
automatic pet feeder that personalizes
your pets
daily calorie intake using their age
weight activity level and food type
with the pet net app you can schedule
and monitor your pet's meals
from your smartphone do you get me do
you are you listening to me
meaning your pet is always fed
even when you're running a little late
okay
stop worrying about feeding your pet the
wrong amount of food every day
the pet net smart feeder will feed the
healthiest portions at the right time
every day automatically listen we all
love our pets the pet net smart feeder
is the best way for you to make sure
you're feeding them right
the right amount every single day but
these things are popular and since the
pet net smart feeder is produced in a
limited quantity each month you need to
get yours before they sell out at
petnet.com
joey today plus you'll get free shipping
also i listen
i'm going to test it again this week
because i just got back on sunday i saw
it was there i asked my wife what she
thought she loves the whole phone
control thing that's the money comes
with an app and you got it right there
when how you that's the whole patois
that if you're running late
maybe you got your cat in a specific
diet maybe he has certain dietary needs
this is what this is for you the pet
net
feeder so the pet net smart feeder so do
me a favor go to petnet.com
joey today and you're gonna get free
shipping what i'm gonna do is this get
your pet in that smart frida
get your pet net smart feeder plus free
shipping when you go to pet net dot com
slash joey that's pet net.com joey again
pat net.com joey this is the future okay
right now patinat smart feeder is the
best way for you to make sure you're
feeding your cat the right way the right
amount every single day so again get
your pets met the pet net smart feeder
plus pl free shipping when you go to
petnet.com
joey
what do you think about that [ __ ]
i love it strong it looks cool
i'm sure you could use it with a dog too
dog cat whatever the hell you need
awesome my man biscuits he is [ __ ]
the greatest my little pip uh english
bulldog
puppy he's [ __ ] the greatest and that
dog
is uh on a regimented thing i would love
to be able to i could hook that up to my
cameras and be able to feed it to make
sure he gets exactly what he's supposed
to get and shut it off remotely go to
pet dot com slash joey [ __ ] and
look at the
look at it see the options you got and i
guarantee you'll love it because of your
travel that's what you really like yeah
we'll be back wednesday night ralphie
may always a pleasure to have you always
a pleasure to see you
you make me happy when skies are sad
nobody knows
how much i love you
you don't get to hang out
you'll never know dear how much i love
this friday
saturday thursday yeah thursday friday
saturday and sunday and uh
man and then off for a week thank god
i mean i've been on uh
tuesday i'm at the
10 o'clock
for uh helping uh native americans get
propane and keep people alive in north
dakota i swear to god it's a great cause
they're nice people all right um you
don't deserve that [ __ ] i remember we
used to have [ __ ] holes in the walls
that weren't the windows you know
it was [ __ ] time nobody knows
[ __ ] yeah
damn it lee
hold on put the
so
you